[Music]
You're pushing, Nuk. You are pushing.
It's either direction.
Virginia, can you get something? Yes.
[Music]
Don't paint the circles. Don't paint the
circles with your arm. Okay.
Yes.
[Music]
So, what are your two shapes? Inward and
outward spiral. The first one is going
to be the outward. Even though it's
going in toward your inner, it's going
outward. When it goes out, when it goes
in, you're bringing it into the inward,
but it's all at the level. Okay? Find
those spirals.
Don't go behind me.
[Music]
Okay. So, you have to look at
I have to bring his shoulder forward.
Okay? Has to pass me. His shoulder has
to pass me. Even though I'm going out,
I'm not going backwards. That'll pull
him backwards. Okay?
So, this has to bring him past me. Then
I can lower it. After he passes me, pass
me. Then I can lower it. And then the
centrifugal energy will bring the other
side forward. Okay? So, boom.
Okay, try
and accept the Muk.
[Music]
That's it, Rio.
Too passing you too much.
[Music]
Good. Watch your foot angle.
You have to find the center. You got to
connect through the elbow.
Drop the elbow. That's better.
Okay. So, we'll watch watch what Rio's
doing. He's just keeping his spine and
just experiencing the ride. That's it.
Okay. Try it again. Everyone go. That's
it.
Got to find their center. You got to
make a lever with their body and they
keep the lever.
Watch your feet.
Don't come back up.
Okay. So, watch my angling now. You
know, you know I can't go
just this way if I have this power
rotate.
So I'm going this way yielding this way.
Other techniques I end up going this
this way. This time this foot's yielding
this way to give me that angle. Okay. So
I'm here
and it's hanging out.
How is he?
[Music]
Okay. Right.
on that new angle.
[Music]
Don't pull.
He the second foot. One, two. That's it.
One, two. Front foot. Back foot.
Front foot. Back foot.
Left foot. Right foot. Left foot.
Yes.
Front foot. Back foot. One. Two. Too
far.
One. Two.
Left foot. Right foot. Yeah.
[Music]
Don't come back up.
Okay. So, one stay
come back up. One stays there. See where
it stays.
Stay there. It's only the very beginning
of the inward spiral and it's low as
Got it. Okay, try it.
in the center. Yes.
Okay. So, we go
out here and I put that center.
It goes up his arm. Boom. There. Okay. I
want to feel that
again cuz he's going that way. It
doesn't take much. Okay.
Hold on. We got a question. Are you
using the coil for that? Yes. Yes.
That's all I have. I don't want to move
my feet. If I move my feet, I'm going to
use whatever they think they're doing
with that tank. Okay, so we'll go a
little slower.
I go here,
right? This foot will have to adjust a
little to get the full yield. And then
boom, is the claw off the back foot.
Boom. Like this. Okay.
Is there more questions?
Okay, let's go.
That's all right. Don't expect the roll.
We stop doing everything. Just push the
center.
you if you do our footwork instead of
your footwork, you'll have a better
chance of finding.
Yes, Theo. That's it.
Find the uh the overall location of the
So, I'm not going to go here and go that
way. So the whole fight
rotates and that happens in the
edi whatever it is for his range but
it's out and then this foot yields.
Okay. And now we're starting to rotate.
Okay. When you just go here, you're just
going to have an acceleration without
the centrifugal energy. Okay. You have
to go boom ever so slight this way.
Okay.
Yep. Be on the ground.
[Music]
Don't
protect from get up
and push that way up. Yes.
step
foot.
You got to be
watching.
The timing is uh I haven't stepped yet
cuz he's passing me. That's where I step
that way. Okay.
So, I let him go that way.
Okay.
Okay. Put your feet down.
Do a heel with the right foot. So that
it rotates just a little.
That's it.
Change. Thank you very much. Try not to
hyper yield and yield your arm. You
won't like the counter.
Good. Good discipline.
Use your leg. Use your foot.
Use the two steps so the fight starts
rotating. Front foot, left foot,
left foot, right foot, left foot, right
foot. And then stay down. Don't come up.
Stay down.
Face. Face. Face. Keep your arches up.
Let him pass you.
Face and project through the arm. Yes.
[Music]
Start locking your spine again. is
getting a little mushy as you're trying
to absorb energy. Let the energy go in
your body, including the downward
energy.
Stay there. You guys
[Music]
Release
tension as you press. All right.
Okay. So, let's watch Chris do the same
exact thing. Taylor do the same exact
thing. Okay.
Good. Okay. Understand? So, that's
exactly what we have on Rio doing. Okay.
So, all that we're doing now is project
projecting the guy away. Okay? If you
wanted to project him away, you would do
that. Okay? And then you could draw your
weapon. Good. He's off your wrist. Okay?
Um to get the top effect, we have to get
the head down. So, as the head comes
back up, the center goes out and heads
back up. Okay?
So,
you have to have your hat ready like
we've been doing. You know, the head
lowered initially, remember? So, don't
reach up for it. Just have it ready to
catch it. It's right there.
Got it?
Don't push it down cuz that would be
contesting. The head goes around you
this way.
[Music]
The same center now pushing on pushing
on the center goes where I was
projecting the centrial energy takes the
legs around it and the head comes back
to me. Now I'm going to for sure fall
outside. It pushes line of gravity
outside.
Make sense?
The more you
rotate
instead of here,
you see keep the pipe moving in this
circle
and be patient for the the center. When
can I push on? Okay. All right. Play
with it. Uh go in two groups because
this one changes constantly. It's never
going to should never be that might be
that that that that. Okay. Two groups
divide into
same thing. Don't try to roll. Just get
launched. Find the bat later.
Yes.
[Music]
Try get out of the way.
You all right? Okay. Come on. Come on.
Stay underneath on the hand. Hand hand.
Keep it underneath low. Don't come up
like that. The head goes down. The arm
goes through.
There
came back to tight.
So you're you're trying to paint the the
the kite, right? You're trying to turn
them.
We're we're not going to turn.
You guys see that? Your center go.
Okay. when your center is all woohoo,
there's no way it's getting back
underneath your line of gravity. Okay?
So,
um,
again, we got to let go of what we think
is happening and just try these things.
Okay? So, the first thing to do is to
stop bringing this hand
over the top.
Keep it on the center. It's on the
center. It's on the center. It stays on
the center.
You see that? Okay. So, if you feel for
it, it would never come up because it
would feel very loose. Okay. Try it
again.
Make sure you have enough room for them
to fall. Okay,
push the center.
Have the head where you can push the
center.
Better
again. I wouldn't let go or try to give
yield on the hand. I don't want really
want to the counter to that and you
don't want to know the counter. Okay,
just let's practice the death
meditation. Okay.
You bend over
starts at uh north camp more towards the
east wall. There you go.
Too far.
Good shot
came up.
That's fine.
Don't take falls if you don't. There's
no need to take a ball, right? There's
no need. You just You just do your thing
and it's there not let that head get too
much forward. It's got to come around
you. Did you hear Sean? I'm sorry. You
got to let the head come around you.
The line is more important though. Don't
worry.
You came over the top.
[Music]
That's it. You went around the center
and then
you got to bring the head down.
The head's not low. I can't project the
center above the head. Okay.
Yes. Yes. Yes.
Got to control the head early on or
it'll come off. No, no, no. You got to
put your hand there already. Get your
hand up. Get your other hand up. Ready
to catch the head
or not?
Catch your other hand up.
Find your center
over the top.
Got to control the head. You got to make
it work. You have to task yourself with
it will work. Can't quit. I can't give
up.
Feel that.
Yeah. That's what you got to do. Yes.
That's it. Now you know why we roll like
we roll.
You got to get the hand. You got to get
your hand ready to catch. I do that for
you. Let's get it right there. It's
actually more Marshall that your hand is
up this way. Okay.
That's it. Yes. There we go. Very nice.
You went behind him. You went old
school. Old school cha there. You don't
enter.
You want the centrifugal force.
You're going behind. You're going
forward on your there. You don't go
forward. He's going to pass you. Did you
pass? Yes. Yes. Yes. In the center.
Don't take the easy way.
Up the center.
Good.
Very good. It can be Rio. Very good.
The head has to be lower than the
center.
face and project.
[Music]
Yep. Yep.
Got to control the head early on. Reach
for the head already. There it is. Find
the center.
Good.
Find the center in the arm originally
and then keep it.
Got to get the head.
Great to hear me though.
Terrible mat awareness though.
They don't go in the same direction.
Head goes in one direction, center goes
in the other. better.
Good.
Good, Chris. That was good. You got to
get that head.
Get that head. Good. Good to run.
You're go. You're injuring past him. So
then you can't project him. Yield with
the left foot. Yield with the right.
There it is right there. Okay.
Reach for the head.
Come up the center. Up the center. Find
your center at the beginning. Don't pull
on it.
[Music]
Good. Good. Rio,
don't bring it back up or the head will
come up.
Good. P.
Up.
That was it though.
Control the head.
Don't go over the top. Good to me,
Travis.
Good.
Find the mat after.
All right.
You got you got to find the roll after
after that bottom apex. You understand?
It's not you're not going to be there
because we're throwing you. You don't
get to roll. Okay. Um
but I hope you can see the difference
between that ka naga and the other kyon
nugget where we were trying to do the
discovery learning. Okay.
Um,
is it on? Yes.
You You would remember how many times I
referred to the video yesterday. I
thought I turned that thing on. Um,
okay.
again. So the go back to the UKI talk
your your job as UK
as far as like where you get your agency
only comes on you will decide how you
land that that's it okay and there's
that is how it is in every other
grappling art anywhere else you get to
decide how you land but in some weird
way
in mid-range grappling
they did this other thing. Why? Because
they have you. They cannot control the
center from the this part of the body.
But once you have the internals, now you
can touch the center from this part of
the body. And now you're back to only
agency you have is how do you land?
Right? You might want to go and say,
"No, I have agency." Uh if in the middle
of the technique I try to do that. Well,
then we're not for training. We want to
do giwaza then the the no is going to do
gi waza back on there. So there is the
hammer fist to your face right or in
this in this um
this uh counter that I was telling you
cuz what what is happening is you have
the center and you're feeling it
dismantled right and so you're hyper yin
heal. You get it? Okay. So as you hyper
your heel, this hand that you've now
brought close to you will go directly on
the center. And now that is where the
coping projection hits you. So instead
of going through your arm or maybe if
you take a little shaving off of it,
there's no taking off anything and you
really you really go fly.
Everyone understand that? So your hair
and he feels the center, he feels that.
hyper immune deals. It goes right to
there now. And that's where you have
projection. Okay. Um and again, no one
would ever know that that wasn't my
target all along. I'm just following the
unit space that he's given me. Okay. Um
we talked about following earlier. But
back to the UK.
Um that kind of is actually what it's
supposed to do when we look at the
marshall aspect. Yes, that that makes it
work because now the guy gets in a
dilemma. He has to get off of there
somehow. You see, there's only two ways.
He pulls out. He pulls out. Cool. I got
a weapon out. I got a weapon out. And we
don't have to drop over my weapon cuz
you gave space in time. Okay. Or he
hyper yin knees and it stays in place.
Cool. Now I go and do close-range
grappling on a guy who already lost his
balance and is trying to regain it.
or he had uh depending on where I am, he
goes hyper knee heels and I follow those
in and I'm into mid-range striking. You
get them right away.
Um but it all stems from I did have a
viable mid-range rack length because
from this part of his body I can still
control his center and therefore his
balance.
But at the energetic level, obviously
that's it. There's no energetics in the
choreography. You're moving yourself.
I'm not moving you. So, how does it
matter how I move and organize myself?
It doesn't. Which is why I can stand
straight up with my chin like that.
But then at the spiritual level,
the has to now unself because that just
up. That's a up feeling.
You see the only way I can do this is
that I I did already. I've already
released itself and I allow this to
happen.
When I allow it to happen, I can
maintain consciousness through this top
spinning world that's happening and I
will find the map to spot.
But when I
have the self, I will lose that
universal speed of life awareness
because the ego tripartite mind cannot
function like that.
And now you grab for things and this is
maybe just making it worse. We laugh at
this freaking or the last second, you
know,
and then we get hurt. Now we take time
off.
But now, as I said, the itself has an
unself aspect of it. Once we train like
this and move ourselves away, no longer
having a need for
very very important. I don't I don't
know what to say. If I if I say Baki
yoga is very very important, it's the
same level of importance. Okay.
All right. Any final questions, comments
on any of the training general
that anything on the training general?
just some of the themes that I've
noticed for myself. So first day just
doing this basic
experience of how one loses
balance.
Um what I noticed was feet becoming
tangled also often
feet.
Yeah. So and it was very subtle. I was
very aware of it and I noticed
um maybe let's go by that the mindset.
Okay, but continue. So feet like this
feet entanglement but Naga's feet are
always ready to take advantage or to
utilize that feet entanglement. Yeah. So
just the feeling of feet entanglement
stumbling
kind of an unusual feeling for Iikido in
general and scary. Yeah. just even that
even subtle, you know, when we did the
adhesion and pull to the side. Yeah.
Really subtle. And immediately I noticed
when it came my turn to do it, I was
giving them the pass like instinctively
like I won't do that to you. Yes. Cuz I
don't want it done to me. Yes. No. I
That's me. Exactly. Now go back. Let's
keep that thought. How many times did I
actually address that repeatedly?
because I this is very common. Um
I think it's part of the culture that
we're all raised in. There's a long
history to make us
um abhore violence.
There's a long history of it. Uh there's
a long history that our nation state
governments monopolize violence that
everyone else is criminal for being
violent. You have to understand that
much for most of human history that was
not the world. So for example
um you know how in the classroom in the
classroom we all went to school at uh
all our desks were lined up in lines
right? remember that
and the state and the the teacher was up
front. Now we today think that that was
about that's about well that way we can
all focus on the teacher. Okay. But
um Fukose's work was done on this. Okay.
And you trace it to it. It has to do
with surveillance. The per one person
can now watch a lot of people. Okay. and
you trace it back and you see the same
kind of system is in the prisons and the
jails where you can't have as many
guards as you have prisoners. So you
have to control space and you have to
survey uh that the space is being
controlled the whole time. But that went
back originally to the military
formations because early on
people would kind of fight independent
like a tribe and you would have
one-on-one. We know from our own arts
history, the samurai fought more
oneon-one, you see,
and much of Europe did. Even the Romans
were the first ones to and and the
Greeks were the first ones to really
organize themselves in this unit. But
even then,
they would have different groups as you
would be working around.
Then Rome disappears.
uh Europe is borrowing some Roman
military technology in terms of
strategy, but they're coming from more
of the hordes that the Romans conquered.
It wasn't really it regimented like we
understand now where the British
colonial soldiers are walking until the
these nation states decided to hand
everybody a gun.
Prior to that, you were of the wealthier
class that you could afford armor and a
horse, right? And so you were that class
was fighting for that class economic
dominance, but quickly with the rifle,
you didn't need all that training and
all that funding.
And we could start giving it to peasants
and farmers. Same thing happened in
Japan. And it was a big question.
What if they turn these rifles on us
because we are controlling them all the
time. Well, we'll line them up.
That's where that came from. Line them
up so we can see which one is doing
something different than what we need
them to do. And that is what made its
way into prisons and into the
classrooms.
The way cities are all graded and
everything like that.
But along with that inertia is to is
also like
the government this violence is fine
when it's for the government. Violence
not for the government is not fine.
So in a lot of countries where you're in
you're not even allowed to carry a
weapon.
The United States has this long history
of the tyranny
of British colonialism where they were
having their weapons taken away from
them for these reasons and their
founding fathers said no that seemed to
be the gateway to the hell we got
ourselves into. And
this is why America still has this kind
of cowboy spirit. Okay.
But there's still a big push in the
United States. No, no, no. You don't
need a gun. The Why do you need a gun?
Why do you need a gun? The already you
see the culturation that only the
government needs guns.
You you you repeat the founding father's
rationale that you need a gun because
the government can do this to you. Why
would the government do that to You see
the totally a a history has taken place
that has moved us away from the founding
fathers experience that governments do
tyrannical things to people. Okay now no
one no one really thinks that in some
weird way
and now violence and the tools of
violence they have a kind of charged
energy to them. So, in my house, there's
weapons all over the place. And one
time, uh, I had one of my, it was when I
was Mr. Mr. Pig, so we did a lot of the
knife fighting. I had my knife sitting
on the nightstand. I don't, I didn't
even have it there for like in case
someone comes in my house. I just had
put it down there on the nightstand. And
my sister, who's older than me, uh she
came into the bedroom to use the master
bathroom cuz the other ones were the the
nightstand is by the headboard. Do you
know the the door the bathroom's that
way? She turned and looked and sort of
started shaking because it looks like it
does not look like a chef knife. You
know what I mean? It was it it started
like really getting her. We're from the
same family, but we have a different
path. And this triggered the the
response. I see this response all the
time, too. When we get recruits who've
never held a gun, it's it's already
charged with a power that brings in
anxiety.
Here too, we do a drill on the like one
of the ways we get close to the striking
and the relaxation.
is you have your hands behind your back
and they'll just hit you in the face
over and over until you get used to
getting hit in the face.
And everyone's more fond of getting hit
in the face than it then you start have
people that don't want to hit the other
people in the face.
I had him cry at trying to do it the way
my sister cried at trying to do that.
I've had recruits too and they do this
will to win where they have this um
boxing match. They have to box each
other after they exhaust each other
physically and then they have to do this
boxing uh and they we're looking for
grit. No quit. You're exhausted. No
quit.
And you'll see again some people like
they'd rather get hit than hit the other
person.
And for me, like I said, we're all just
fighting this history that made what was
once normal,
especially for a warrior.
We're in a warrior art, but somehow
we don't have the warrior that warrior
comfortability, that warrior culture
where the weapons are not charged for
me, you know, with that emotional power.
So, I would say first, yes, that's
probably more common than not. And it's
going to get more common as the modern
nation states do more and more to
monopolize violence. And um I would even
say this, Buudo itself, budo itself as
the Japanese developed it
is part of this government
monopolization
of of uh the natural human tendency for
violence. And like we're trying to make
it unnatural. So for example, I
mentioned earlier I project and draw a
weapon. I draw my handgun. In the old
days, I would project and drew a sword.
You see that?
I don't think it's an accident that all
these Buddho traditions have stuck with
uh ancient impractical weapons
because they're not charged and they
can't be used against the government.
You're you're going out in protest or
rebellion against the government with
swords would only be symbolic.
you show up with AR-15s,
no one's going to think it's a simple,
you know.
So, yes, naturally, this is just in us.
There's no way around it.
Um,
okay.
It's one of those things.
I see this unself in me. I see a viable
practice that is complete.
But it goes through this
charged repelling aspect of warriorhood.
In other words, it's not a dead for me.
Modern Christianity is a dead is a dead
religion.
Modern Iikido is a dead art. Bible means
it has all three components. They're all
concentric. They all work together. You
can experience it. It's oriented towards
an experience at every level. It's
functioning as stated, as designed, as
instructed. And everyone can do it. You
just got to do these work. This work.
Okay, that's what viable means.
Quick question. Yeah, the three
components being the three components of
the of this art as I teach it is there's
the martial aspect, there's the
energetic aspect, and there's the
spiritual aspect.
the
let's just call that the way.
Here I am. I've been cultured
that I found the way, but my culture has
veered me away from it.
In my world,
my culture is a birth of the ego
tripartite mind.
So for me, this choice is not not
between my culture and the way. This
choice is between the light and the
darkness, between God and the devil.
So the choice is easy, but
there's still in each of you, you're
like, you have to get to that area where
you're like,
I don't like this violent part.
But I do like the part about I have to
find all the seeds of violence in me.
And to find those seeds, I have to pass
through this violence as my culture has
defined it. See,
and I think that choice is as easy as it
is for as as I frame it for me.
And I think what you'll see as for me,
when I push you, do it. Do it to them.
Do it to them.
I'm not pushing you to vi to the
violence.
I'm pushing you into the violence
because you're not doing it from a
selfie
point of view. You see? So for example,
you're early on contested or you're
early on uh
stop the energetic engine early on
because you were already stuck in the
self. The technique is not going to work
and you already know it.
And so then you powder puff the ending
then but you think you were nice. You
see? So if my guess she can testify to
this
I'll say like do it and then you'll
realize you couldn't.
You see that is the only reason that I
will make you go past that other that
other stuff because you're hiding the
the moral. They're hiding the selfieing
with the moral cause. Okay?
If you're not selfing
and you're just killing people, then I
will tell you, hey, you don't need to do
it at that level. You do it at this
level.
Um,
like you saw me do it without there.
And in that sense then as you you you
made the you calculated what is the
equation in which I'm choosing A or B
from and then you go I'm going to go
ahead and choose it. You're going to see
that we're actually not doing what that
culture was telling us that we're doing.
We're still doing the unselfing.
And when you don't sell
The expectation is that you're not ever
hurting anyone. Okay? That you can do
the technique with the same level of
control from the same level above
selfie. Super slow and super gentle.
Even taking off the throat if need be,
right? And you don't feel like you're
not training enough.
But I can't get there if I don't ever go
there. That's that's the thing in modern
IPO never goes there. So what we do
instead in modern IPO is
I won't throw you I won't do that to you
because you're going to do it to
yourself. But then if you don't you see
then that violence as I defined it
starts to well up in you right you're
even to me
when you get angry or frustrated from
them it's the violence that's a violent
act to me as I defined it see
but let alone no one never stops there
because if you kept doing that sooner or
later you're going to give them a what
before that Los Angeles
podcast, you know, they would they would
do that enforcement stuff, right? The
guy's always bragging about it. I was
the enforcer. Well, what are you
enforcing against? Somebody who wouldn't
take the like, well then what what do
you mean? What's this take about? You
get what I mean? You throw people or you
don't throw people. What do you need an
enforcer for someone who didn't take
Cammy?
There's no shame in that statement.
He says it just fine. Like you see that
and that's how the will to power works.
We come up with some moral reason for
now go ahead and sell.
Or you'll have that kind of passive
stuff like this place isn't really for
you.
Now you kick them out.
Where's the communion there?
Where's the reconcile of the world
there? I'll reconcile as long as you do
exactly what I say, exactly how I want.
So,
you're going to have to pass through it.
I've never seen anyone
who either is violent
or who either avoids violence
that isn't selfish.
It's it's a weird thing and it's hard to
understand because of the history of our
culture, but if you get yourself in
there, you'll see how that's actually
true. It's actually true. So,
um,
the most gentle, compassionate cops
are also the ones that can kill you
cold.
Those those things go together, right?
But we've been told that it's not that's
not the truth. But in our tradition here
from Iikido, our samurai
narratives is filled with those examples
and we should not be so ready to go. I'm
doing
their tradition,
but I think I understand it better than
they do. Let's get a little doubt going
with ABC. What were they actually
talking about? Okay. with this readiness
to cut a head or to have your head cut
and still cut off three more heads with
your head cut. Like everyone knows
that's not possible, but what's he
talking about? See,
get in there and you'll figure it out.
Um, this isn't Cobra Kai, you know, in
that show. There's no mercy in this
dojo. There's a lot of mercy in this
dojo. uh it just doesn't feel like it
because of the suffering, right? Um but
you have to pay attention how much the
schedule changed, how many breaks we're
taking, what we're doing, what are we
working on, what do we stop working on.
You see, all that is,
as I said in the preface to this camp,
it's your training. What do you need to
get to the next level for where you're
at? Okay.
And that would include for your next
level of problematizing himself.
You bring the problem self into your
train, not try to
he about
hang in there, right? I get it and just
expect it's normal. They did this to me.
They did this to me. Okay. Um
I don't feel guilty or shame or cowardly
or anything like that. This is what they
what's happened to us.
I just found it is curious because you
know doing systemic stuff punching
people not a big deal for me. Well,
there's things to work on there. Like it
it was like very specifically for me
personally and what I've struggled with
is that kind of falling and I've said it
even on the looks terrifying and I'm not
I wouldn't say I'm terrified but
definitely it's not I'm not comfortable
with it. Yeah. And rarely ever
experienced that in system and I feel
like normally I have a lot of control. A
lot of control. A lot of control. Yeah.
You only a couple times, you know. Yeah.
You know, judo champ 300 counter, you
know. Yeah. You have you'll have those
every month. Even even in the Fed stuff,
everyone wants whoa, what the You
know, you're like, you didn't want that
to happen. You didn't expect that and
happen. Uh it's just here. That's all
that happens, right? That's that's the
difference.
But even then, even then the quality of
the the throw is even different. Yes, I
would agree. I would agree. Yeah. Yeah.
All that kind of stuff. But that to me
that's what makes it potentially
spiritual because it triggers itself.
100% agree. Does everyone that's why you
can't you can't dial past that. You can
dial down but you can't dial around it.
So I I when when I did that case on
Fouching, believe me, she's struggling
with selfie even at that pace. Okay,
does that make sense? Um
e even as uh
I didn't throw that knee because that
was going to shut Chris down right away.
Okay, that was going to hit him on the
hit him in the in the solar plexus and
then he would have just collapsed right
there. It would look something like
this.
Right. They're laughing because that's
exactly right.
It would we would not be training them.
You see some someone on on on Ronin,
right? He'd see that knee. He He knew he
up. He'd see the knee push the
knee down. He'd get the hell out of
there and he'd come right back in. Okay.
And so even though the knee's not thrown
cuz he blocked it, he woke up. Okay? And
then he would come back in
and everyone's different because
everyone's at a different level. Okay?
And the teacher has to the teacher can't
go
and uh
not throw the hammers. Do you know what
I mean? Because then he gets to practice
the fear and the selfie and the need for
control that you're not helping them
that way. And yes, that you know, to be
honest, that just does not feel good.
That's a big part why um
I'm just not interested in
trying to get as many people because the
there's a lot of people that like the
idea but can't do the idea. Do do you
know what I mean? And so you're just
you're going to have to always pull back
and then they get to just self.
And now you're actually hurting them
because from your perspective that's the
seed of all suffering
and you're just reifying yourself. But
now
it never feels good.
It's not there's no pleasure in it for
me.
They had that I go through cycles. If
they know, you got to remember I'm done.
I'm not hitting you guys anymore because
I I go through these cycles.
We had one guy,
Julian was the last one.
Julian decided that he didn't know if it
was real or not. So decides to test it
and um
I can feel all that. You can feel it.
And I think it was a similar technique.
I know it was a hammer fist in the face.
So he decided he was going to turn in
the technique. Um but instead of turning
out of this hesitation, just turning out
of the the intention
uh and with an assault. So
I ended up hammerfisting him and it
broke his nose and his blood went all
over the place. And then he w he like
woke up. He felt guilty as hell. He's
like, "I shouldn't have doubted you."
And uh but why did the doubt come?
Because the training
was had to be soft enough for him. You
see the the doubt is coming from the
self. The self can't do this level of
training. So the training had to be
softened for him and it's just feeding
him. And so he had to go to this level
and now it broke him and required me to
go to that. And I was like, I'm not
doing this for no one else. This is for
my sons only. My sons are those who will
align with me, male or female.
Just like the sons of God.
So that's why I don't I don't I'm not
going to let you in because I'm not
going to reify yourself and if it's
going to take this extra level of
violence. No, we're not doing that.
Again, my try to motivate you. You do
it. You do the alignment. You don't need
the whacking stick. Don't need it.
Here's the self. Here's what it does.
Here's what it feels like. Here's what
it looks like. Let go.
So, very similarly, we we make these
jokes. You've heard me make these jokes.
Like Chris even got a shirt for me cuz
it says or not. I tell you what to do
and you're not going to do it. And then
I always go or not.
I think a couple of those came out this
week.
Or how about you try our technique? You
heard that one,
right?
Early on. We had our own little
preface into this camp. And one of the
things I said
to this group cuz he already knows how
to do this. You felt that firsthand.
He's going to whatever you do, he's
going to throw you
whatever thing. But I had to tell this
group
whatever you need to do, you make the
throw work.
But why?
Because they're selfieing and getting
themselves in situations where the throw
cannot work.
So even just recently, just right here,
you're
footing around the throat and I
go, "Do it." And then you bounced off of
him
cuz you have that tension in your body.
I think any actual spiritual mentor
has to struggle with that. I mean it
does take like is sense.
I learned a lot from him. Nowhere near
what you're seeing here because he had a
lot of students. They can't do what I
do. But he was influential in my life.
But he didn't give a about no one
else.
The second you
did your own thing, he would let you do
your own thing. He would not take the
time or the energy nor experience
the repercussions of reeling you back
into alignment.
And I think that this is related, right?
Like I'm not going to do it to you. And
I that's how a lot of teachers are.
They're not going to hold you
They're going to let you do your own
thing. That's why the mat looks
everyone's doing their own thing. That's
why when I stop you, it feels so weird
to what maybe you're used to or why we
go back to a progression to give you the
chance to get it to get it before we go
on. Do you see why the lessons feed off
of the other lessons and we don't jump
all over the place? You could jump all
over the place when you don't give a
what everyone's doing. You see, who
cares?
So even from the teacher's point of
view, there's, you know, we understand
violence and this grander thing, it's
like they don't want to do this, but I
am going to make them do it by making it
impossible for them to not do it.
So,
just like I told you, the way you were
moving your feet that time, I'm going to
come up with a version where you can't
move your feet like that. That's the
kind of violence he wanted to do it one
way, he wanted to do it another way, but
I wanted him to do it this way
because I wanted him to use the force
engine, which requires the unself.
All right? And then I combined that with
everyone that wanted to find their
inside foot. I'm going to take away your
inside foot. We're going to sweep the
leg. You see, that's the kind of
violence.
Everyone wanted to be able to find that
inside foot and just calmly lay down.
But there's no training in that.
And there has to be something in you as
the teacher who's like going and saying
it's going to be uncomfortable. It
really is uncomfortable.
We're not honest, but you have to be
able to go, "No,
we have to go there." And so, we go
there. And then you balance out for risk
and safety and all that kind of stuff,
but you can't cave into the initial
impulses. This is going to be
uncomfortable. So, let's not go there.
Okay? So, likewise, you and yourself,
you have to do that. And if you do that,
your teacher can do it more while having
to do it less.
Okay? If you're ready to be
uncomfortable, then we you're working on
it. We're doing it. Okay? If the
uncomfortability immediately makes you
want to stop
have any but but stopping broader any
frustration, any depression, any guilt,
any shame, anything like that is all
resistance towards we're going there.
You're already dead. Go. What do you
What's there to be ashamed of? What's
there to be guilty of? What's there to
regret? What's there to dread?
I'll close with this.
This is why traditionally
The way
of the sons of God is in this alignment.
It goes down. It goes down too. So your
first alignment is with the teacher.
This is a micro version of this other
alignment.
You can't. This voice is going to talk
to you sooner or later and you can't go
hold on. Wait.
How about if you can't negotiate?
Well, the same thing. That's that's what
you practice with your teacher first.
That's terrifying.
But the other one you don't have a shot
if this is terrifying.
Hey, don't move your foot there. Move
your foot here. If I can't do that
because it's too terrifying or because
there's too much self that I have to let
go of. If I can't do it just because
that person told me to do it. If that's
not enough to get me to do it, there's
no way
I'm going to align with the divine.
There's no way.
It's like if I can't do
drill one, there's no way I can do drill
two. There's no way I can do drill
three. There's no way I can do tima.
You see, it goes on like that. This
cultivation field between the teacher
and the guest
is it's way easier.
If I can't do it here, I can't do it
there. So,
it should be a big deal. The teacher not
have to say or not or how about try
ours. It shouldn't have to be.
[Music]
And I think if we do all that, we won't
even get we can circumvent this. I'm
doing something to someone else. Do you
know what I mean? It gets filtered
through the teacher
and it gets filtered through the
teaching. I'm not doing violence.
I'm creating an unselfy